do you sense that there's a drifting
of uh what is the threshold to be a
progressive or is is there it should we
use Progressive synonymously with uh
Democratic socialists
I think we should not use it
synonymously with Democratic socialists
and this is where there's another
linguistic confusion and a political
confusion so we'll first talk about the
linguistic one
social democracy versus Democratic
socialism very similar words in a
different order okay
my the way I operate is democratic
socialism is actually a form of
Socialism where one would seek to
socialize ownership of the means of
production as an example social
democracy is a very uh highly regulated
form of capitalism the likes of which we
would see in northern Europe Denmark Etc
these are very different things I
associate progressivism in 2023 with
social democracy and would consider
Democratic socialism a form of actual
socialism that is different is it we're
no longer talking about a capitalist
organization of society so transition
from one to the other is a fundamental
shift in house in how Society operates
then absolutely and when you talk about
social democracy you're talking about
socializing a couple more things than we
socialize in most modern uh capitalist
countries I had this conversation with
Patrick David recently social democracy
is okay we've socialized the military
already in the United States we've
socialized some health care in the sense
of like the VA and Medicaid Etc we're
talking about socializing a couple more
things still in a capitalist country
Democratic socialism would be something
beyond that and and as someone who is
not a Democratic Socialist myself I'm
I'm maybe not the best
advocate for explaining exactly how that
system would function but it would have
some version of socializing ownership of
the means of production businesses Etc